THE ISLANDERS ARE AT THEIR BEST
IN TRANSITION.OUT.
ZACHA INTO THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE GAME
TONIGHT AND ALMOST OPENED THE
ANDERS LEE HEALTHY AGAIN FOR
PUNCHED AHEAD.
MERCER WITH A STEP!
MERCER BACKHAND AND SAVE
THEY SCORE!N HAD TO MAKE THAT F
SAVE AND HE WAS WAY OUT OF HIS
NET.
RIGHT HE
BEAUVILLIER.
A BEAUTIFULAN IS CREDITED
WITH THE SECONDARY ASSIST.
DE
[ INAUDIBLE ] THIRD BEST IN THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE AND SAW
THAT AS RAL ZONE.
WAHLSTROM IS TRYING TO GO
UPSTAIRS.OOT
RACES.
>> Steve: CENTERING TRY AND
KNOCKED DOWN IN FRONT.
HERE COME
AWAY.
BRATT HAS HELP.
PASS BACK FOR BRATT AND HE
CONTINUES SOROKIN.
MERCER ON THE DRAW AND
CONTROLLED BY ISLANDERS PUCK. A
SEE DOUGIE HAMILTON PICK UP
PAVEL ZACHA. OUT JOHNSSON PLAYS
BACK AND TAKEN BY
MEMBER OF THE NEW JERSEY DEVILS.
WHAT A MOVE HE MAKES.
HERE IS THE OPPORTUNITY.
SMITH SETS UP BRATT FOR
MAYFIELD.
CLUTTERBUCK AGAIISLANDERS GET T.
ISLANDERS SKATE THIS AWAY.
HERE COMES B ABLE TO
HAVE THAT
JESPER THIS ACROSS.
SIEGENTHALER AGAIN.
PLAYS
PIKE. TO
FIND MERCER.
>> Steve: DOBSON OFF THE DRAW.
SENDS P AND IT IS
TATAR!
FIRST UP FOR THE QUARTERBACK
WITH LOU AND ISLANDERS IN THE
HOUSE, THIRD PERIOD IS UNDER WAY
WITH THE DEVILS THIRD.
YOU KNOWD.
INTO BETWEEN THE ISLANDER
DEFENSE.
LOOK AT THE SAVE.
I THOUGHT TATAR DOBSON.
HE IS CHECKED ALONG THE FAR
WALL.
DAWSON MERGCER EXTENDS THE LEAD.
I COULDN'T TELL IF JOHNSSON
FOLLOWED UP AND IT LOOKED LIKE A
SOROKIN.
>> Ken: WHAT A NICE PLAY BY
JESPERERLTON AGAIN.
SCORES! JUST SHOOTS THAT
PUCK SHORT